welcome back to cbs this morning today
is the deadline for wireless companies
to implement technology to stop
those dreaded robocalls they must tell
the federal communications commission
whether they are complying with the
agency's requirements and if they don't
they could face penalties it's all
happening under a new acting fcc
chairwoman and our consumer
investigative correspondent anna warner
sat down with her for an interview you
will only see on cbs this morning anna
good morning to you who do we send our
thank you notes to
yeah good morning tony right start
sending him now the new
acting fcc chairwoman is jessica
rosenwursel
she's a lawyer who's not shy about this
she wants the wireless carriers to know
she's serious about cracking down
the illegal robocalls keep coming in
this is an important message regarding
your current credit card account
your social has been found some
suspicious for committing fraudulent
estimated 4 billion of them ringing in
on people's cell phones in the month of
may alone
12 calls per person on average of course
the issue that everybody wants to talk
about is robo calls
and acting fcc chairwoman jessica
rosenworcel
knows it of course oh my gosh they're so
annoying
we want to stop robocalls and make it
easier for consumers to safely answer
the phone
today is the fcc's deadline for most
phone companies to put in place
call authentication technology a step
crucial she says to stopping scammers
and what that means is when a call is
being made
a carrier can tell that it really is the
person who they say they are
on the line basically the carriers have
to verify yes when
anna warner calls that's actually anna
warnock that's not a scammer not a
scammer
and in april the fcc added yet another
rule
requiring wireless companies to report
whether they're complying
under penalty of perjury i mean swear to
it is basically what you're saying
swear to it because i want you on record
saying that you are doing these things
to stop robocalls
and if you lie to us we're going to come
after you the fcc is done playing
teresa murray is consumer watchdog at
the u.s public interest research group
we're seeing 10 billion dollars worth of
fraud a year against consumers
not to mention three billion dollars a
year in wasted time
from you and me answering all these
stupid phone calls so i think that the
fcc
has finally heard enough from enough
aspects of our
society that they're done phone
companies say they're well on their way
in a statement industry group ctia says
nationwide providers have already
implemented call
authentication protocols and call
blocking solutions
and the industry is unwavering in its
commitment to protect american consumers
from illegal and unwanted robocalls but
their moves rosenwersel believes should
have come
earlier and she doesn't hesitate to
fault former chairman ajit pai
and the trump administration the last
four years we saw a huge rise in the
number of robocalls
but i don't think we saw an equivalent
rise in our enforcement
and our activity to stop them to sum up
you're saying in the previous
administration there was not enough
enforcement
and they didn't get these protocols in
place fast enough yes
in response pai told us in a statement
that the previous fcc took
unprecedented steps to protect consumers
from the scourge of unwanted robocalls
and he said he looks forward to seeing
what the current fcc does
given that robocalls and spam texts have
gone up dramatically
since january 2021. so are you promising
to fix all that now
i am promising that we are not going to
stop until these calls stop we are going
to try to be as creative as possible
with the laws we have
and if that fails us we will go to
congress and press for more laws because
we've got to stop these calls
well the next target date is september
when any carriers
who didn't report to the fcc could
theoretically
have their calls blocked but rosenworcel
said she'll be making some assessments
along the way
of course even if the vast majority of
robocalls stop
the scammers are likely to find other
ways to reach you
uh everybody through social media of
course and the new thing is
text messages yeah that's really
annoying that's
the next wave if they can't get you on
the robocall so thank you to jessica
rosen worsel yeah yeah
that's a very unusual name i like it no
one i don't mind the text messages
because the text messages don't like
come
you're not like getting out of the
shower to run for the phone when you get
a text message
interesting that you say that because
that is what the experts say
tony is that text messages don't seem to
bother people the way that the
calls do sadly they bother me more
because it to me text messages feel more
personal
usually the robocalls are the robocalls
are you know they i get the same phone
call from different numbers almost every
day
i pick it up and don't say anything and
then they just hang up yeah and it's me
going gail yeah
all right not a recording anna thank you